محمود شاب سودانيه يعيش في ليبيا منذ
حوالي 28 سنه يعمل في مجال تقنيه
المعلومات ولكن في هذه الايام تشغله اوضاع
الحرب في السودان عن عمله وتفقده تركيزه
بسبب خوفه على اهله ووطنه طبعا في الماكل
وفي المشرب وفي التواصل
ونحن خاصه اللي موجودين في بلاد الغربه
القلق عندنا مضاعف جدا لانه ما بنقدر
نتواصل مع كل الاهالي مشاعر محمود لا
تختلف عن غيره من ابناء الجاليه السودانيه
في ليبيا فهم في حاله ترقب دائم ومحاوله
تتبع لكل الاخبار رغم تضاربها وانتشار
عشرات الشائعه على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي فيها البيعات وفيها البخات
القديمه من دول تانيه
فهذا الشيء يؤثر على الناس ويؤثر على
الوطنين بشكل كبير تبقى مشاكل انقطاع
الاتصالات والكهرباء على المناطق في
السودان احد المشاكل التي تحرم السودانيين
في ليبيا من التواصل مع عائلاتهم
والاطمئنان عليهم بشكل مستمر
فعانينا جدا في اننا نتصل بالاهل وتمكنا
الحمد لله واطمئنينا على كثير
وللاسف يعني في الاخبار المش جميله
يعني عندنا عندنا ناس اصيبوا
في ناس ينتقلوا الى رحمه الله سمعنا بعض
الاخبار المؤسفه عن ضحايا في يعني صفوف
الاهل للاسف كانت دكتوره وكانت يعني من
المسعفين وبتحاول تسعف يعني في المصابين
والجرحى لربما عاش افراد الجاليه
السودانيه هنا اوضاع مشابهه في ليبيا خلال
السنوات الماضيه ما يجعلهم مدركين للمخاطر
الحقيقيه للحروب والخسائر والاوجاع التي
تخلفها
منير الاشهب طرابلس العربيه